die tier solche afrikanische
schweinepest hat deutschland erreicht
das bestätigte
bundeslandwirtschaftsministerin julia
klöckner
nachgewiesen ist die solche bei einem
wildschwein kadaver in brandenburg für
menschen ist die infektionskrankheit
ungefährlich schweinehalter fürchten
jedoch mögliche exportstopps und große
wirtschaftliche schäden der kadaver
wurde wenige kilometer von der
deutsch-polnischen grenze entfernt im
spree-neiße-kreis gefunden in der
gemeinde schenkendöbern und wir wollen
schauen in die region bild reporter
michael sauerbier ist vor ort
seitdem ich gestern nachmittag von dem
befund erfahren habe habe ich meine
mitarbeiter an die stelle geschickt und
die haben alle notwendigen maßnahmen vor
ort zur sicherung des der reste des
kadavers und der stelle vorgenommen die
es also abgesperrt jetzt und mit
entsprechenden einsätzen
desinfektionsmitteln ist die stelle dann
auch desinfiziert worden
und hier gehört gerade auf einer
pressekonferenz der landrats der
betroffenen region um vor ort ist unser
bild reporter michael sauerbier meldet
sich hier im spree-neiße-kreis im
äußersten südosten brandenburgs wurde
deutschlands erstes wildschwein mit der
schweinepest entdeckt nur sieben
kilometer entfernt von diesen
elektrischen schweinepest schutzzaun der
seit anfang des jahres eigentlich das
eindringen der solche verhindern sollte
am rand eines abgeernteten maisfeld bei
säften so heißt der kleine ort wurde der
kadaver am freitag entdeckt am montag
den behörden gemeldet und seit heute
morgen donnerstag gibt es die offizielle
bestätigung des bundes labors in
greifswald seither hat der landkreis
eine reihe von schutzmaßnahmen
eingerichtet vor allem 3
sperr kreise im umfang von 3 5 10 und 30
kilometer vom fundort wo nun starke
beschränkungen gelten für betreten ernte
und fleisch mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bate schaut euch
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren